good morning believe nation today's
message is start with a spark over you
Bono when we started our week we
couldn't even play our instruments we
really couldn't we
we formed a band before we could even
play and we were 16 and we didn't know
where we were going and we just decided
to go there together it's just four of
us in the kitchen in global city in
Ireland and Larry Mullen jr. is the
drummer on the group he started only he
just kind of pinned a notice to announce
notice boarding school is starting a
high school band and we got started and
actually looked at me I didn't even know
if I wanted to be in a band and but when
we started to play together when we
started writing selves together I don't
know why but we felt we could we could
make a living out of it and we felt that
there was something special a spark that
was different and between us a lot of
the other bands that was under me gusto
better spark and we started with our
little spark and we've kind of stranded
a bit amounts of flame I suppose and
there's a sort of spire right now most
people aren't happy with the spark most
people expect instant success as an
entrepreneur they expect that lots of
bunch burners have success and I'm
talented and I'm smart why can't I
figure this out and my business should
work in the first six months I fell into
the same trap when I started my very
first company was 19 I became an
entrepreneur as my first kind of real
company I guess I thought it would be a
lot easier than it was
I saw the articles and the magazines and
the shows talking about these successful
entrepreneurs I thought I could do this
everything else I had done that I
applied myself to I had success with so
I could do this too and I failed over
and over and over and over again and you
realize and for those of you who've been
in business you know it's way harder
than you think it's going to be and a
lot of people just quit too soon a lot
of people give up once it gets hard
because the spark isn't enough we all
have the spark but to turn the spark
into a fire
you need to work it and work it and work
it and work it and work it and the thing
that gets you through was the absolute
passion for what you're doing if you can
find the thing that you love doing that
you would do even if you weren't getting
paid to do it then you have to find the
way to keep going even if doesn't make
sense
you lost all practicality even if
everybody around you telling you that
you're crazy and stupid if it's inside
here you have to keep finding a way to
keep going if you take on part-time jobs
maybe you go work for somebody else
whatever it is you have to find a way to
keep going if you've lost interest in it
it's not exciting sure anymore it was
just something that you were trying to
make some money off of then you should
quit and move on to something else if
you find that spark and you think that
this is something that I really really
have a passion for I want to do then you
have to find a way to keep going don't
quit too soon and turn that spark into a
fire so the question they today is I'm
curious what's your spark what's the
thing that gets you excited what's the
thing that gets you motivated what do
you love about your business leave it
down the comments below to be curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to David a special David thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book here one word it really really
means a lot to me and I hope you
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you guys again tomorrow
morning for another shot events presto
[Music]
so do you have any advice for someone
who would like to start doing creative
writing but has no idea where to start
whatsoever um depends are you the kind
of person who arm do you read a lot I
read a lot yes and I write snarky emails
but that's not I've been told they're
very good I mean wouldn't you say
creative writing do you want to write
fiction do you want to write humorous
essays do you want or there's inaudible
and I would think you want to do stories
yes okay so my advice is start writing
stories just like do it really it's
almost as simple as that it's start
writing so pick a bigger style pick a
theme look at the kind of you know you
are not expected straight out of the hat
to be a brave and original voice
producing fine and wonderful fiction
it's much more like you know the first
pancake on the griddle which is gonna be
this weird black messy thing that you
will either give to your dog or to a
child trying to convince them yeah it's
nice
hey you know if it's you will you you're
right you finish things you start the
next thing you write that you finish it
someone there you get reasonably good
arm and these two people or do you just
yeah I the the the point I was found
that I I would always learn more about
what I'd done the moment I saw it in
print or the moment these days probably
the moment you'd see things up on the
web but yeah II um to people um but the
most important thing when you're just
starting out is write the next one a
fume that you have you know a million
words inside you that are absolute
rubbish and you need to get them out
before you get to the good ones and if
you get there early that's great that's
really my biggest advice thank you read
everything you can read outside your
comfort zone and write a lot let's talk
about that initiation of the dream how
did that start and had that come about
I'd started a business before that I
raised four million bucks of other
people's money started a web
Marketing company went boom and bust
with the first dot-com boom and bust I
knew I wanted to make it as an
entrepreneur and start another business
but I had no idea what I wanted to do
and so for inspiration I went surfing
and I planned a five-month surf trip
around Australia and Indonesia the
inspiration came before I even left I
wanted to capture photos of myself and
my friends that I was going on the trip
with while we were surfing out in the
water and no camera existed that allowed
you to do that and so I set out to
develop this wrist harness that I could
put a single-use disposable camera into
and surf with it and if I didn't even
mean it to be a business idea
I just wanted to document my experience
on this trip and as soon as I got it
working well the light bulb went off and
I realized oh my god there must be so
many other surfers in the world that
want something like this so you started
with wrist straps essentially but how do
you go from wrist straps it's very
simple to hardware into actually
developing a camera I wanted to use
higher quality cameras with my wrist
strap to capture higher quality photos
but every camera that I would use with
the strap surfing I would break the
camera because cameras weren't designed
to be used during rigorous activities
like surfing and what I ended up doing
was I spent two years going to trade
shows the camera trade shows around the
world to look for a camera that was
close to what I would want to design
after a year and a half about a year I
found it and got the manufacturer to
agree to make the modifications and
begin building the cameras for me I
actually did the deal without ever
meeting the actual company is all email
I had one phone call where we could
barely understand each other because of
language barrier we're ten year in
Shenzhen I wired my five thousand
dollars for the tool so to be dizzy the
mold to be made because it was it was
actually cheaper just to wire five grand
and to fly over there meet them have a
business trip and I just figured okay
we'll just go for it
and they ended up being legitimate and
we were profitable from day one
because it was just me one employee we
just had no overhead and rolled one good
production run into another and slowly
scaled it and the GoPro that that
everybody knows today has been built on
two hundred and sixty-five thousand
dollars of capital mom made it into
college on his third try and became an
English teacher with no computing or
engineering background
he's an unlikely tech Titan but he says
he was captivated by the internet from
the moment he first saw it in 1995 when
he came to the US as a translator I
never touched keyboard before I was
using computer before and I say what is
Internet is a Jack you know such
whatever you want on the Internet
how can I search what I search me is it
just the type I don't want to type
computers so expensive in China I don't
want to destroy it
he said it's not a bomb just the type so
I touched the first to work of beer at
that time very slow come out the
American beer Japan beer in the German
beer the new China beer so I was curious
and it was typed China no China no data
came back to Hangzhou with one dollar in
my pocket scared worried and I came back
and I said I want to do something called
Internet